you know what happens Meek Mill and I'm
going undercover on the Internet
it's actually me seriously it's actually
me core how important is Instagram to
Meek Mill career I don't know how much I
was popping his flesh degree Twitter
that left no vet can someone explain to
me why and hi Robert Kraft and meek Mill
are friends
it's like be weird question but you know
we hustlers why is that surprising cuz
he white and wealthy and I'm black again
when I don't know why we friends at
picasso 7 180
how does it feel the head at album under
year chant i feel good to have people
supporting my album you know I put a lot
of time in the recording it I'm so
grateful I know what people like it it
got some princess underscore do you
think that possibly be a Meek Mill tour
with a few artists on your album I got a
tour coming up this February it starts
in February cars in one division
tourists edition y night tour so you
know we will add people to the tourists
times afford right at violence five one
seven
can we get us what would we do official
remix with Meek Mill please for my
sanity and then shout out to push it
take you know that's very possible hit
push your teeth each set you can make
that happen
at creature seven six seven how did you
feel when you got that whole verse what
was the first thing you did add to us
the first thing I did was send it to my
homies and let my homies here and it was
loving it I always got like my three
four people I always sent music so I've
been doing in my whole life so yeah love
my homies head posted YouTube is that
little snoop on his chain if you own the
low snoop Louis Newt lost his life to
gun violence it was the first artist
outside - dreamchaser records he was
like my little brother and he lost his
life probably about four years ago to
gun violence so you know I'm putting on
my chain of represent my interior is the
other person on my chain she lost her
life when I was a kid was this isn't it
pick up Willie is illegal - pink Oh
Willie that's what they say wait what I
don't know we're picking up Willie is I
don't know what they mean with it it's
not a crying Papa woody but I went to
prison for popping the world
a State Penitentiary time apart normally
sell the meat milk and tour because
these are prohibition how does he make
money I can't or I can go anywhere I
want in the world
you had the ask for permission on
probation ready crab helped him get out
of prison I would said he helped me he
spoke up for me and the time I need he
spoke up for me in front of the world
grab a crab meant to market Ruben and
we've been cool ever since really met on
the plane went to Miami choked out and
we've been cool ever since more Twitter
and BK skinMan and the rap career is
over or you feel like you are done what
do you see yourself doing what is your
legacy gonna be
I will continue to use this platform
that you had I don't know I'm just gonna
keep on doing the best I can and again
the best man I can use my platform to
bring awareness to and justice across
America at row safe at Meek Mill
what do you fear the most in life well
when I'm feeling once in life I would
say dying that's easy
Wikipedia he became acquainted with
another one of his father's brother who
went by the MC name Grandmaster Nell who
was a pioneer disc jockey in the late
nineteen eighties Philadelphia's hip hop
scene he has also influenced by the
independent hip hop artists like cheap
vodka whom he used to emulate watching
on their DVDs yeah that's true I used to
watch 12 on the streets a lot of Philly
rappers on them DVDs like my barber
himself Shawn brown rock monster cheap
raw real dollars really had a lot of
artists when full of Duffy who really
inspired me a lot to want to keep
pursuing rent more quo was meeting
imprisonment just no meat no
imprisonment wasn't just I don't think I
would be back on the street it was
Justin I had a bunch of people support
me it was this Meek Mill believe in God
yes I believe in a guy I don't know if
it's a person that I believe in but I
believe in some hard in the world posted
Instagram and Meek Mill Bay who was the
song about let there hurt though this
song is one of my favorites on
they're talking about the song almost
lip it's not about anybody specific
you're just talking about experience and
dealing with women and dancing we're not
really taking every woman I've dealt
with serious I was not specifically
about anybody what's the name of the
song that song don't have a name - yeah
one of the songs I recorded and then
make the album cut I probably recorded
200 songs and picked 19 so that one
didn't make the album cut I think is
saved in my computer as the motivation
or something like that next even more
Twitter at forego you know how does Meek
Mill had a vocal stamina - yeah about 85
of his lyrics
I'm healthy yesterday this is the way I
read I just read progressively I come
from a DMX tight busta rhymes era and
that's where I came out expressing
myself I would say elves on the school
how does meat milk motivate to you I
don't know I just know a lot of younger
people to me say that I motivate them
and inspire them I think watching me
come from absolutely nothing on YouTube
from the age of 14 and build my career
up inspires people when they see well so
probably growing on camera Windows
Pullman and meek mill collab drop I
don't know when I'll collab one drop yet
but we're definitely working on a collab
and that's coming out soon
oh it's looking good so far we create an
app to win the first stage then yell are
doing is Meek Mill banned from entering
the UK cuz I really don't get why he
hasn't been here yet does he think he
doesn't have fans here cuz he really
does know I try to go to the UK a few
times I think because I was on active
prohibition that the climbing from
coming but I was they gave me a chance
to come to UK I'm coming for sure at CRD
backness how many songs can you make in
one day my best song making then prizes
like seven songs in one day I would say
on a bad day probably a half a song boom
that's it
signing off the internet